I saw where it felt like golf was moving
closer towards coming back and then I
saw where he may have golf hopefully
have golf and the beginning of June as
we woken the Commissioner Commissioner
how are you Dan it's great to hear your
voice and it's it's uh we're hanging in
there where are you right now I am I am
at TPC Sawgrass making this phone call
from the Players Championship Media
Center take me back to the Players
Championship because you played that
opening round what went into that
discussion did you have before the
players you know we had we had started
to we've got a Christ man crisis
management team that does the week that
meets weekly that had been meeting on on
this subject over really the two prior
weeks and we started to talk about the
potential impacts but candidly Dan we
were thinking it was further down the
road and we came into the week we began
our practice rounds and on Wednesday the
eve you know of our first round I came
out of a reception that we were hosting
I looked at my phone and the NBA had had
postponed their season and so we went
into a period really of 30 hours where
we made the decision one to play Friday
without fans and then ultimately decided
on Thursday night late that just based
on you know the rapid escalation of this
coronavirus that we needed to cancel for
the safety of our players and our fans
what is the game plan now is we target
the first week in June at Colonial the
game plan is to continue to spend a lot
of time on our to make certain that
we're creating the you know safest most
responsible environment for our players
we've announced that we're going to play
without spectators we need to refine our
testing system our testing protocols
again to ensure that safety we're
looking at every single movement and
interaction to create the safest
environments for players caddies and
Media members that will be broadcasting
the event and other key constituents and
continue to really look down at what's
happening in that marketplace so work
with local city state officials make
sure that everything that we're doing is
validated and supported and that as we
get closer and closer that we're in
position to execute the event but we're
you know we recognize that we're also
operating in a world of uncertainty so
you know looking at all the different
scenarios that can play out and how
we're going to respond and handle to
them handle them but for us we felt like
you know our sport does lend itself very
well the social distancing we think this
is the right approach to come back and
at the same time you know we felt it was
important to be able to show our players
and our fans what the schedule would be
through the end of the year assuming
that we can get the right systems in
place
how much conversation have you had with
the President of the United States on
this we've have had actually had
conversations during the week of the
players as we were deciding what we were
going to do write that in there and I
was fortunate alongside a number of
other leaders in our industry to be
invited to a conference call a couple
weekends ago and then to this committee
that he's formed on the re-emergence
revitalization of our country
a committee of sports leaders and it's
an honor to be on it and it's it's also
wonderful Dan you cover so many sports
have done so brilliantly over your
career there aren't too many times when
when our industry comes together to
tackle and the problem you know it's a
problem solve and that's one of the
things that we're doing across leagues
across leadership and to have the
support of our government right now is
incredibly helpful what would change
that time frame June in in Texas you
know I think I think you know you just
look at what happens on the ground there
so it really depends on where we are you
know with cases that event is in Fort
Worth in particular and where we are
with the virus in that marketplace where
we are you know across the
entry where we are with testing we need
we're going to be reliant on large-scale
and rapid response testing and we feel
like we're going to be able to
administer a program it's going to that
will allow us to ensure to the greatest
degree possible a safe and responsible
environment but we're going to need you
know we're going to need the support of
everybody on the ground in that
marketplace and we're going to need to
know that we're comfortable that for
those that are on property that we feel
like we've created the safe environment
that we intend to the first thing I
thought of was you have an international
field your stars are all over the world
to get them to be coming back to the
United side of the country and then to
fly back in what what kind of hurdles
are you looking at with getting
everybody to be in one city at the same
time
well well to that point we have 93
players from 28 countries and we have
been in close contact with all of our
athletes since we left the players
championship right now we believe we
have 25 players that are outside the US
in roughly 35 caddies so you know we're
going to have to make certain that we're
doing everything we can you you know
everything we can to be of help to them
as they seek to come back and continue
to monitor travel restrictions border
closures and other things that will be a
consideration for them as they look to
return you know the beauty is that if
we're able to play under this schedule
our players can't play every single week
so you know we've announced the schedule
that takes us through the end of this
FedEx Cup season Labor Day weekend and
and all the way up through through
December so we're hopeful based on what
we're hearing that we'll be able to be
you know to get our players back here
and give them enough time to prepare
particularly those that are seeking to
return the week of the challenge I did
say to Bubba Watson yesterday I said why
don't you guys carry your own bags so we
don't even have caddies out there mm-hmm
what do you think what a Bubba say well
he was okay but I think he needs help
reading putts and things I think that
sounded like listen I think I think the
role
that our caddies play caddies are
essential as it relates to the
competitive performance of players and
and and we we feel like we can create
the the right environment for the player
caddy relationship when we return but
your point your point is I think it
really hits on the exercise that we're
going through literally looking at every
single movement that a player in a caddy
has from the moment that they land you
know in that you know at that Airport to
the moment that they leave and really
thinking through what are the steps that
we can take to create the safest most
responsible environment you really can't
leave anything for chance when you have
this amount of uncertainty in front of
us Commissioner it's good to talk to you
hope you're well and hopefully we get
golf back here soon they're always great
to talk to you thanks for the great work
you and the team do thank you that's a J
Monahan PGA Tour commissioner